hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the end old test the indle
test is an example of a biochemical test
that helps us to distinguish between
different kinds of bacteria based on
their biochemical or metabolic
characteristics and the indle test in
particular is one that allows us to
identify bacteria as being either Endel
positive or negative based on their
ability to convert tryptophan which is
an amino acid one of the building blocks
of proteins so to convert tryptophan
into a compound known as Endel using a
chain of enzymes that are collectively
known as a tryptophan in the tryptophan
ace and so this probably makes sense
remember that when we talk about enzymes
we're looking at words ending in ace a
tryptophan ace would be an enzyme or in
this case a group of enzymes that break
down tryptophan which is shown here if
you're used to looking at amino acid
structures there is your alpha carbon
right there with its hydrogen its
carboxyl group and its amino group and
this would be its R group right there
it makes tryptophan so this right here
is tryptophan and it is reacted with
water so it is a kind of hydrolysis
reaction along with those tryptophan ice
enzymes to break tryptophan down to get
three different products so they are in
dole which is this one right here and
pyruvate and an ammonium ion so this is
a kind of deamination reaction
it's called deamination because it's
severing this amino group from the
carbon and it's bound to that's what
gives us the ammonium ions that's why
it's a deamination reaction and you
might be asking yourself well why why
would bacteria even have this chain
events
this trip Tiffany's capability if
tryptophan is an amino acid it's a
building block of proteins well why do
we want to break it down well it turns
out that these products can have a few
different uses in a cell so for example
in dole which is this one right here it
is an intracellular signal molecule so
it is a molecule that can be produced by
a cell and then excreted in order to
allow that cell to talk to other
surrounding cells it helps regulate
activities like biofilm formation and
also certain theory Lentz capabilities
and so that's why a bacterial cell might
need to produce indole by breaking down
tryptophan hmmm pyruvate one of the
other products here you may have heard
of pyruvate before as the end product of
another process called glycolysis so it
turns out that making pyruvate this way
means that it can feed directly into the
Krebs cycle also known as the citric
acid cycle the TCA cycle the
tricarboxylic acid cycle these are all
different names for the same cycle and
that are part of the aerobic respiration
pathway so glycolysis and the Krebs
cycle and the electron transport chain
these things work together to generate
ATP so that's a another way that the
cell if it was needing some ATP might
break down some tryptophan to get the
pyruvate to send it into the Krebs cycle
to help generate that ATP so these both
of these products have some some
necessary effects that sometimes a sound
means so now we are kind of hijacking
this ability to convert tryptophan and
indel as a way in the indole test to
distinguish between different kinds of
bacteria so let's talk about the
procedure so first of all you have a
test organism some bacterial culture
that's been cultured from a patient for
example and in order to identify it you
want to determine
it has this ability to convert
tryptophan to endl or not so you would
knock you laid some sterile media with
this test organism and the sterile media
there's a few different kinds that are
possible one is sim media another's
nutrient peptone really any media that
has enough tryptophan in it to be a
starting reagent for any tryptophan ace
that's present then that maybe it would
be good enough for the annual test but
these are certainly the more common ones
the new incubate at 37 degrees this
human body temperature for 24 to 48
hours and this is to give the test
organism time to convert tryptophan to
Endel if in fact it's able to do so if
it has those tryptophan eeks enzymes
then after 24 to 48 hours you add half a
milliliter Kovacs reagent and that's
like a few drops so it's not not a lot
and then you observe for the presence or
absence of a cherry red color at the
surface so if you've got two tubes and
this one was inoculated with an indole
positive bacterial culture then this
right here the surface solution will get
a bright cherry red color that's because
the chemicals are in this Kovacs reagent
can react with indole if it's present to
create a dino Nazz the rosen dual dye
and that has a cherry red a color
however if there is no indole present
because there was no trip tiffany's to
break down the tryptophan that was in
the media then you end up just kind of
having a yellow color here I don't have
a yellow marker so I'm using orange
today but this would be a sort of a
bright yellow instead of a bright red
and so some examples here of into a
positive bacteria include ecoli era
Mona's hydrophilic and terracotta
cyclist species that would be indle
negative meaning that they don't have
today's enzyme so they cannot convert
tryptophan to indle those would be
species of Salmonella and Klebsiella 2
as an example and there is also a
another kind of form of the indole test
that's called a rapid spot test it's not
as sensitive as this to test and so it's
used less frequently but you might need
to know that that spot test exists if
you are interested in learning more
about enzymes you can see my video on
introduction to enzymes I also have a
video about aerobic respiration where I
talk about the krebs cycle a little bit
if you're interested in that and then I
have a playlist with lots of videos
about many other of these kind of
biochemical identification tests things
like the citrate test the lecithinase
test the DNA's test the indole test and
so if you're interested in learning more
about those and please check out that
playlist and thanks for watching biology
professor today